Snoop Dogg was quite literally my
favorite twitch streamer
most of the time Snoop was just chilling
smoking playing games with basically no
commentary it's like being on Discord
with your friends late at night on 420
but sometimes we got something truly
special like the time Snoop rage quit
and then forgot to turn off his stream
for over eight hours am I still
streaming or how about all the times he
flexed his acting chops with some
intense role playing watch out there's
an alien right here I told you watch out
Carol
watch out
oh come on Carol now there are some
haters who claim that Snoop went live
multiple times with no audio but Snoop
would never make such a silly mistake
twitch just muted him for playing music
was it a little scoffed sure but I'd
give anything to have it back come on
man what the [__] is you doing us